>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mark Sweeney: Good morning,
and welcome to the second day
of the Library of Congress'
conference Facts or Fictions,
Debating the Mysteries of Early
Modern Science and Cartography,
a celebration of the
500th anniversary
of Waldseemuller's
1516 Carta marina.
I'm Mark Sweeney, the Associate
Librarian for Library Services.
I hope a lot of you were
able to join us yesterday.
Needless to say, our distinguished
speakers enlightened us
about many crucial, intriguing
aspects of Renaissance cartography,
and then illustrated their
remarks with images of maps
of enormous significance for our
greater appreciation of the quest
to explore and understand
the physical world.
Last night we also had the pleasure
of learning about the Mapping
of the Elusive Southern Sky, which
was the subject of the annual Jay I.
Kislak lecture, brilliantly
presented by Dava Sobel.
Today the examination of
Renaissance cartography continues
with more exciting
presentations and discussions,
as well as an open house at
the Geography and Map Division.
I hope you can stay with us
throughout the remainder of the day.
At this time it's my privilege
to introduce the 14th Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
As you may know, Dr.
Hayden was sworn
in as Librarian on
September the 14th.
So unless I'm mistaken, I believe
this is her first appearance today
in participation in an international
conference as Librarian of Congress.
So please join me in welcoming
one of the brightest stars
in the firmament of the world's
libraries, Dr. Carla Hayden.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Well,
good morning, and welcome.
It is truly a pleasure to be
joining all of you this morning
to celebrate really one of
the most amazing treasures
of the Library of Congress.
The 1507 World Map by
Martin Waldseemuller,
known as the birth
certificate of America,
is truly one of the
great masterpieces
of the art of mapmaking.
The only surviving copy of
the map, which names America
for the first time,
is part of the largest
and most comprehensive collection
of maps and atlases in the world,
here at the Library of Congress.
The library has more than 5.9
million cartographic items
from the 14th century
to the present time.
It covers every country and
subject in formats ranging
from medieval manuscripts
to digital data.
This morning it is my honor
to launch a great website
that was a successful collaboration
of the Library of Congress
with the Galileo Museum in Florence.
This comprehensive, interactive site
contains more than 11 hours of video
which charts every aspect of
the life of this important map
and highlights the
science and the culture
of the times in which
it was created.
Digitally interactive
projects like these,
which bring to the web important
treasures from our collection
and our collective past, are
changing the way scholars,
educators, students,
and the public interact
with the library's vast collections.
Waldseemuller's maps were created
at a time of great revolutions,
both scientific and cultural.
I believe it is these revolutions
and how humanist geographers
and scientists reacted to them
make story told by this website,
which is relevant for us today.
The world has changed from
one of medieval isolation
to the more progressive
ideas of the Renaissance
and our modern world
came into being.
In order to bring this masterpiece
of the early scientific revolution
to viewers around the world,
the Library of Congress
and the Galileo Museum have joined
together to create a website
which fosters not only an
understanding of the past,
but also hopefully helps all of us
to navigate our technological
and scientific future.
I would like to give
special appreciation
to Professor Umberto Tombari
along with Dr. Paolo --
and I practiced, I have
to tell you [laughter] --
along with Dr. Paolo Galluzzi and
Dr. Filippo Camerota, Director
and Vice Director of
the Galileo Museum,
for their support of this project.
And I would also like to
congratulate everyone else involved
in its creation, both here at the
Library of Congress' Geographic
and Map Division and
also the Galileo Museum.
And now it is my honor to welcome
His Excellency Armando Varricchio,
Ambassador of Italy
to the United States.
[ Applause ]
>> Ambassador Armando Varricchio:
Good morning, everybody.
Dear friends, ladies, and gentlemen,
it's always good for me to be back
at this great, great Library of
Congress, renowned for the worth,
depth, and breadth
of its collection.
A very warm thank you to the
newly-appointed Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden,
a warm welcome to her new role.
To Dr. Hayden -- who, by the
way, managed to pronounce my name
in its preferred way; I'm really
puzzled by this [laughter] --
was responsible for protecting
and disseminating the knowledge
of the largest library in the world.
We offer our full collaboration
on the many inspiring
and mutually-enriching
projects yet to come.
A warm welcome to Professor
Umberto Tombari,
President of Ente Cassa
di Risparmio di Firenze,
which financially supported the
project; to Professor Paolo Galluzzi
and Professor Filippo Camerota,
Director and Vice Director
of the Museo Galileo; to Laura
Campbell, and to Ralph Ehrenberg,
and John Hessler of the
Library of Congress.
A Land Beyond the Stars, what name
could be better for this conference,
bringing together the
knowledge and excitement
of the unknown yet to explore?
This reminds me, by the way,
back in July I attended
an extraordinary event
in the JPL NASA Center
in Pasadena, California.
On that very night, human made
possible to send to Jupiter's orbit,
by the way, an artifact called
Juno with the sentimental also link
of Juno finally uniting to
Jupiter where Italian scientists
and physicists were a great part.
So this to show that the
great journey goes on.
But as you are probably aware,
the Library of Congress together
with the Museo Galileo di Firenze
has organized this wonderful
exhibition of the "Universales
Cosmographia" map
by Martin Waldseemuller for the
first time in Washington at age 500.
This blended map is
widely recognized
as being the first [inaudible]
inscription of the name America,
of the newly-discovered
land just 15 years prior,
the Land Beyond the Stars,
discovered on the other
side of the ocean.
In Vespucci's own words, "Those new
regions which we found and explored
with the fleet we may
rightly call a New World,
a continent more densely
peopled and abounding in animals
that either Europe, or Asia,
or Africa, and in addition,
a climate milder than any
other region known to us."
Well, at that time climate
had not changed yet.
But Italy didn't only have a
role in naming of the New World,
this Carta marina is also referred
to as the new Vespucci map,
as it credits the discovery
of the new continent goes
to the great Florentine explorer
and cartographer who believed
that the new lands were not part of
Asia, but rather of a fourth part
of the globe, as he used to say,
and different from previously
identified continents.
It is, therefore, only fitting
that the city which he hailed from,
Florence, has deciphered
the map in its entirety.
In fact, Museo Galileo, renowned for
holding one of the best collections
of scientific instruments
in the world,
has created an impressive digital
tool which makes the map available
to everybody, thus
providing a fascinating look
into what truly constitutes
an immense encyclopedia
of knowledge of the time.
Not only does it tell us about
Waldseemuller's cartography,
it also tells us about his life.
So our long-lasting and very
productive collaboration
with the Library has yielded
another winning project
which not only benefits those
of us who are here today
and who can admire first-hand
these beautiful works,
but the many who are not able to
join us today and who will be able
to enjoy this splendid
work online in the future.
Dr. Hayden, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well,
thank you, Ambassador,
and thank you Dr. Hayden.
A website like this
doesn't come without cost.
It doesn't come without
the need for support.
And also, the purchase of the
map itself, its encasement,
doesn't come without support.
So we have to thank all
of those external donors
who helped us both develop the
website and purchase the map
and its preservation here
at the Library of Congress.
And with that, it is
my great pleasure
to introduce Professor
Umberto Tombari who --
from Florence, who is
primarily responsible
for the actually funding
of the website itself.
Professor Tombari.
[ Applause ]
>> Umberto Tombari: So thank you.
Thank you to everyone.
Professor Hayden, Your
Excellency, my dear colleagues,
I am deeply honored to be here with
you today in this hallowed setting,
the Library of Congress,
that is widely recognized
to be the largest library in
the world, with many more books,
recordings, photographs, newspapers,
and maps gathered in its collection.
[Inaudible] form of [inaudible]
that preserves and provides access
to a rich, diverse, and enduring
source of knowledge ready to inform,
inspire, and engage [inaudible]
in our intellectual
and curative endeavors.
I cannot help but feel that
there is an especially close bond
between this institution and our
foundation, Florence Foundation,
which has been supporting and
promoting culture in Florence
and in Tuscany for almost 200 years,
while constantly tailoring the way
it does [inaudible] changing times.
A perfect example of how it
does, that is the presentation
of this website with
its huge impact.
A website we have funded and
produced with the magnificent team
from the Museo Galileo in
Florence, and in close cooperation
with the Library of Congress,
which I ought once again to thank
for its amenability
and its hospitality.
The Waldseemuller map
is a compendium
of a [inaudible] knowledge
which, then as now,
underscores the close tie binding
Florence and America under the aegis
of a traveler as extraordinary
as Amerigo Vespucci.
If you're here today to maximize the
potential and deepen our knowledge
of this monument of global
cartography, sharing in the project
for the website Professor Galluzzi
will be illustrating to you shortly,
we owe it to the ethos
of conservation
of which Florence is one of the
world's unquestioned capitals.
That is why we are
intervening in support
of the Opificio delle pietre dure
di Firenze, Florence's illustrious,
historic, and indeed world-famous
school of restoration that is
in danger of losing valuable skills.
But we need to look ahead.
And I firmly believe that it
is our duty to develop new ways
of devising different takes on
the past in a contemporary way.
These are the goals to which
my foundation [inaudible] my
foundation, of course, is
strongly committed today,
and to this end we have
embarked on a strategic project
to launch a service model formulated
to foster a new renaissance capable
of [inaudible] Florence's splendid
humanistic tradition in a new,
more modern and more dynamic light.
A new renaissance, I said.
A new renaissance that
should matter to everyone.
In this connection, we are currently
busy identifying a selection
of programs that use the
ecosystem of beauty as their source
of inspiration for
projects, and schemes designed
to promote cultural innovation and
social development, and boldly open
to partnership and
to the [inaudible]
of systematic interaction with
those like you and like us,
while sensitive to such issues.
So what I'm talking about
here is new direction.
A concrete example of this is
the cooperation set in motion
between our Museo Galileo
and the Library of Congress,
a project that has been given a
generally enthusiastic reception
by Ambassador Armando
Varricchio, to whom I would
like to express my
heartfelt gratitude.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: And now it's time
to actually look at the website.
The website was, in fact,
launched officially this morning,
so it is available online.
But for a preview before
we actually show it live,
I am going to give you Professor
and Director of the Galileo Museum,
a great Galileo scholar in his
own right, Dr. Paolo Galluzzi.
[ Applause ]
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Thank you,
John thank you to the institution
that is hosting this event and
has offered such a cooperation
in making possible this dream.
There were many reasons why
the Museo Galileo has devoted
so much energy designing and
producing an exhaustive website
on Waldseemuller "Cosmographia
Universalis."
The first reason is that this
document pays tribute to the city
in which is home to
the Museo Galileo.
I obviously refer to the Florentine
Amerigo Vespucci whom Waldseemuller
credited as being the
first to realize
that the lands beyond the Atlantic
that he had reached were not
the western coast of India,
but a new continent, the fourth part
of the world named
America in Amerigo's honor.
The Florence in which Amerigo was
born and raised had no seafront,
nor did it have fleets capable of
crossing the vast ocean expanses,
yet in the 14th and 15th centuries
Florence was a highly-advanced
center for geographic
studies and research.
Francesco Petrarca, Giovanni
Boccaccio, Angelo Poliziano,
Paolo dal Pozzo Toscanelli, who
was not only a great astrologer,
but also a reference
for Brunelleschi
and inspired Chirstophorus Columbus,
all these eminent Tuscans took an
interest in the region of the earth,
their cartographic representation
as well as their inhabitants.
These pursuits were a distinctive
feature of the humanist movement
of which Florence was
the dynamic hub.
The very last years of the 14th
century witnessed the arrival
in Florence of the Greek
manuscript of Ptolemy's "Geography,"
a text unknown in Medieval Europe.
The event triggered
the revival of interest
in geography throughout Europe.
Ptolemy's text, enhanced
by maps of the known world,
was copied in countless manuscripts,
often richly illuminated.
It was translated into
Latin and the vernacular,
and ultimately disseminated
through printed versions.
Is return to the West of this
text has set in motion a process
that lasted throughout the
entire humanist period,
a process characterized not only
by sophisticated philological
interpretations
and intense curiosity about
distant lands and their peoples,
but also by the quest for the
most effective solutions to --
for faithfully representing the
known world on vellum or paper.
The second reason that
led us to take
up this challenge concerns
information technology.
Waldseemuller's chart offered
a fantastic opportunity
to demonstrate the
exceptional contribution
that the intelligent
use of IT can make
in showcasing the historical
heritage
and defining new publication formats
that fully exploit the
web's unheard potential.
During the last three decades, the
Museo Galileo in Florence has been
in the forefront of this area
of experimentation and research,
taken advantage of three
fundamental assets,
the world of documentary resources,
including a large research library
and iconographic archive,
the presence of highly-qualified
scholars in the history of science
and technology, and the availability
of an in-house multimedia department
endowed with the human resources,
skills, and technical
instruments necessary
for digital production
of the highest quality.
We have over the years developed
other projects aimed at conceiving
and testing [inaudible]
digital library models.
Let me just mention one among the
many examples which you can explore
on the Museum Galileo website.
I refer to the recently-published
Galileo Teca,
which perfectly mirrors our quest
for the best solution to organize,
publish, and share on the
web historical documents.
The Galileo Teca is a corpus
of closely-integrated archives.
You see our nine archives --
Each one of the [inaudible]
is one archive --
offering fast and easy access to
the text, manuscripts, biographical
and bibliographical
records, chronology, images,
and all the information needed
to conduct in-depth research
on Galileo and his work.
Just make browsing
of the nine archives,
a huge amount of information, all
linked transversely and vertically.
And there's a fantastic research
volume available for scholars,
wherever they're from
via the web connection.
The same programmatic vision
inspired the website devoted
to Waldseemuller's map.
We have designed it as a repository
incorporating visual documents,
printed and manuscript sources,
videos illustrating the functioning
of nautical instruments,
and the method
for producing cartographic
projections,
three-dimensional simulations,
diagrams, interactive timelines,
slideshows providing context,
and all the resources necessary
for an easier understanding
of the massive amount
of information contained in this
exceptional cartographic monument,
information that would
be impossible to decode
with traditional publishing methods.
The complex IT architecture that we
have built is not an end in itself.
It can be reused for other projects.
We are planning to apply it to
showcase with similar browsing tools
and facilities another
great cartographic monument
of the early modern age,
Fra Mauro's world map,
just over half a century
before Waldseemuller's map.
Similarly, the Galileo Teca
structure forms the skeleton
on which we are modeling a new
and even more challenging project,
the Leonardo Teca, a
digital environment
to facilitate easy online access
and study of Leonardo's manuscripts,
truly a labyrinth if
ever there was one.
Today's event [inaudible] for great
satisfaction for many reasons.
As the head of an institution that
endeavors to keep up with the times,
to explore innovative research
paths, and test new methods
for organizing and disseminating
knowledge in the global universe
of the web, I am particularly happy
about the fruitful cooperation
that we have established with
so prestigious an institution
as the Library of Congress.
I trust that new opportunities will
soon arise for us to join forces
on other ambitious projects It
is no less a satisfaction for me
to witness the completion of a
project that started with an idea
that flashed through my mind a few
years ago when I was first able
to admire Waldseemuller original
map at the Library of Congress.
How could one best explain the
infinite messages contained
in this cartographic monument,
illustrate the theoretical
and practical knowledge that
made its production possible,
and reconstruct the context
in which the map was made?
It immediately came
up -- occurred --
it immediately occurred to me that
the most effective method would be
to transform the map into a vast
digital repository accessible
on the web, accompanied
by the technical
and intellectual instruments
that needed to explore the map
and help the public to understand
its historical importance
and uniqueness.
The proposal to produce an advanced
web-based system for exploring
and contextualizing the map
was greeted with enthusiasm
by our colleagues at the Library,
especially Laura Campbell,
then Associate Librarian
for Strategic Initiatives
and the Librarian of
Congress James Billington.
The expert and heartfelt
participation of Ralph Ehrenberg,
and John Hessler, and the entire
Geography and Map Division
of the Library of Congress
proved essential
to the preparation of the website.
I thank His Excellency,
the Ambassador of Italy
to the United States, who offered
his generous and decisive support
for this project and to its
presentation in Washington, DC,
as well as his expert
staff, among whom I would
like to mention Professor
Renato Miracco.
This ambitious enterprise would have
been impossible without the support,
collaboration, and
unstinting encouragement
of a time-honored Florentine
institution,
Ente Cassa di Risparmio di
Firenze, foundation committed
to sponsoring initiatives such
as this which convey the image
of Florence and Tuscany
across the world.
The Florentine foundation has
also promoted the publication
of an elegant volume
accompanied by a flash drive
which illustrates the
scope of this project.
I express my appreciation
and gratitude
to the foundation's chairman,
Professor Umberto Tombari.
Let me conclude, emphasizing that
the largest share of the merit
of the project goes to its de
facto author, Filippo Camerota,
Deputy Director of
the Museo Galileo.
Filippo drafted most
of the materials
and coordinated the preparation
of the website, entirely produced
by our multimedia -- museum's
Multimedia Department.
He will illustrate for you
the structure and content
of this resource, available as
[inaudible] today in Italian
and English on the website
of the Museo Galileo.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well, now we will
actually dig into the website a bit,
and it is my great pleasure to
introduce the primary drafter
of a lot of the content as you
will see it, the Associate Director
of the Galileo Museum,
Dr. Filippo Camerota.
[ Applause ]
>> Filippo Camerota: Good morning.
I would like to introduce myself
as the filmmaker of this project,
just because this was
the way in which I worked
with the graphic designers.
As you heard, the website is online.
It's already online since
early in the morning,
so if you have a tablet here you can
follow me in this brief navigation
through the new lines
of digital library.
The website, in fact, is a --
we conceive that as a model for a
new concept of the digital library.
And it's a tool -- an educational
tools and a research tool addressed
to a large public, possibly to
any kind of user from scholar --
from students to scholars.
Unfortunately, we cannot
see all the movies
because it would take too much
time, and we don't have that time.
So but we will see
some very interesting
and representative samples.
So we -- I think it's the case to --
to directly to the introduction here
on the upper part of the homepage.
>> The world map designed
by the German cartographer
Martin Waldseemuller grew
out of an ambitious project
to present the latest
geographic knowledge compiled
from recent Spanish and
Portuguese ocean voyages.
The map was drawn in
1507, using data gathered
by Amerigo Vespucci
during his expeditions
to the New World from 1497 to 1504.
Waldseemuller christened the
new lands America in honor
of the Florentine navigator
who was the first to recognize
that the coasts he had explored
belonged to a new continent.
By portraying the new world
as a separate continent,
Waldseemuller's map
constituted a huge leap forward
in geographic knowledge, marking
the end of the traditional division
of the Earth into three parts.
The map in the Library of Congress
is the only known surviving copy
of a printing that, according to
the author, totaled 1000 copies.
Long thought lost, the map
was rediscovered in 1901
by the Jesuit historian and
cartographer Joseph Fischer
in the library of the castle
belonging to the family
of Prince Johannes Waldburg-Wolfegg
in Baden-Wurttemberg, Germany.
The map, made up of 12 sheets,
measures 138 by 238 centimeters,
or 4 1/2 feet by 8 feet.
Purchased by the Library of Congress
in 2003, it is now on display
in the Great Hall of the
Thomas Jefferson Building.
This website was designed
to allow a wider public
to appreciate the wealth of
information contained in the map
and to decipher its
structure and graphic symbols.
The website aims to serve
as an experimental model
for a new digital library concept.
>> Filippo Camerota: As you can see,
the 12 plates composing the map
are displayed on the homepage
as gateways to 12 exploration teams,
and the general index is
available here from the --
through the sitemap where we can see
the 12 chapters which are subdivided
into approximately 200
sections with 41 --
comprising 41 videos
and 25 3-D animations.
And the topics are arranged
according to an ideal sequence,
but of course, users can
move freely in the website --
through the website, just choosing
the theme of personal interest.
Let's see, for example, from
here the humanist interest
in cartography.
>> The mapmakers engaged
in universal cartography
in the 15th century were
often learned humanists
who provided subtle interpretations
of highly-diverse sources,
ranging from classic Greek and Latin
authors to written and oral accounts
by merchants, travelers,
diplomats, and ship pilots
as well as graphic source --
>> Filippo Camerota: This is
just a short sample of the kind
of movies you will
find in the website.
And from here -- oh, excuse me.
From here you can read
the text of the movie,
which is useful sometimes just
to learn better some
names or information.
Here, this is the historical
context.
So the first chapter is
devoted to the humanist interest
in cartography and geography.
And there are lots -- several
slideshows with introduction
of the two protagonists
of this history,
Martin Waldseemuller
and Matthias Ringmann.
Matthias Ringmann is always
a little bit in the shadow,
but in fact he was the humanist
behind the cartographer,
and he played a very important role.
Possibly he was the one who
invented the name America.
Here we have a timeline where the
fundamental steps in the production
of the maps of Waldseemuller
are shown since the foundation
of the Gymnasium Vosagense
in 1490, up to the printing
of the Carta Marina in 1516.
Let's go to the second chapter,
which is an interactive exploration
of the map with a terrific
enlargement of the details.
We can see, for example, here
a very interesting detail --
one of the most curious
details of the map.
This is the wasp, which is an
important element of the coat
of arms of the Vespucci family.
In fact, it's depicted next
to the portrait of Vespucci --
Vespucci as a cosmographer of
the New World in front of Ptolemy
as the cosmography of the
old -- the Ancient World.
From here we can see separately the
12 sheets where we find some details
which are not visible in the
mounted map, like these notes --
handwritten notes by
Johannes Schoner
who was the owner of the map.
Now it's still out
of focus, I think,
but it takes a little bit of time.
And there is the possibility from
here to rotate the map in order
to read the names, which are written
in a vertical or diagonal line.
And the, of course, presentation
of the two protagonists
here, the two cosmographers.
And we can see the
coordinates traced on the map.
And that's traced by Schoner in
order to design these old maps
from this map of Martin
Waldseemuller.
One of the most interesting elements
of this exploration
is the visualization
of the 26 original maps by
Ptolemy, which here we can see
through the maps depicted by
Henricus Martellus Germanus
for an edition of the
cosmography, which was probably one
of the most important
sources for Waldseemuller.
For example, here we can find
a name -- oh, excuse me --
W here with the same
corrupted Latin word --
I don't know if you can read,
columpnae [assumed spelling]
with a P instead of
columnae [assumed spelling].
And this is the word used and
written by Waldseemuller, too.
So possibly this was one -- you
know, the main source for him.
And of course, all the
maps are visible here.
And we can read all the
cartouches of the map.
There are 159 cartouches.
And we give for them the Latin
transcription and the Italian,
and in this case English,
translation.
These islands were discovered by
Columbus, Genoese Admiral acting
on the orders of the
King of Castile.
So it's full of information.
It's actually an encyclopedia
of geographical discovery.
And we have a lot of also
[inaudible] kingdoms and provinces,
185 names, or 100 names, toponyms,
for the new world which are compared
with the same names
found in the maps --
[inaudible] maps, which
is useful just
to learn how a name was developed,
and invented, and transcribed
by the several cartographers here.
You can see the mountains with
their name, rivers, and so on.
So this is a way to read what is
normally unreadable in the map.
Chapter three is a
visual translation
of the book printed
joined to the map in 1507,
the "Cosmographiae Introductio."
Here we have the chapters of
the book and the geometric
and cosmographic definitions
given by Waldseemuller,
but they are translated in
images just to allow everybody
to understand what is going there.
This is the definition of the
sphere, which is made not just
as a simple surface, but
as a surface made of many,
many points equidistant
from the center.
But here -- down here you can see --
you can read the definition
given by Waldseemuller.
Or from here you can
go to the Latin text,
which is in the digital library,
which open exactly on the page
where the definition
of the sphere is given.
You can read, of course, the
entire book just this way,
which is always very useful
because you have an idea of the --
you see, there are no images in
these books, just a written text.
So I think in this case
the translation of text
in images is quite useful and
also very direct in the --
in translating and giving the
information about cosmography.
Not always is it easy to
understand what is equators,
all the [inaudible], and so on.
And the images are given
in three dimensions,
but sometimes you can compare
an autographic projection
with a prospective projection just
to understand what is a
local horizon, for example.
An autographic projection is
just a line tangent to the Earth,
but you can understand
that actually is a disc,
is a circle which can be visualized
in the middle of -- in -- of the --
of an [inaudible] sphere,
[inaudible] sphere
for us is the most common
instrument which gives information
about the structure of the sky.
Cosmography, of course,
was important,
cosmography as the
science of sky also
to understand what is on the Earth.
Going from the sky to the
Earth, this is the path
that Waldseemuller is
following in this book.
And here you can finally
have the information
about the several places
in the world.
The appendix gives still a visual
representation of the quadrant,
which is drawn in the book,
but it's not actually clear
in the [inaudible].
And here we have the end of the
book, which is the description
of the four voyages
by Amerigo Vespucci,
which here are visualized
with four images.
These images can be seen as a movie
in section eight, for example,
devoted to the New World where
we have, just to have an example,
the third voyage of Vespucci.
>> Vespucci's third
voyage remains a subject
of historical controversy
to this day.
Scholars have voiced serious
doubts that it ever occurred.
For Ringmann and Waldseemuller,
however,
who published Vespucci's
letter to Piero Soderini
on his four navigations
in the appendix to the
"Cosmographiae Introductio" of 1507.
The voyage did take place, and
it was one of the most important.
In his letter, Vespucci writes that
he outfitted a fleet of three ships
and sailed from Lisbon on
May 10th or 13th, 1501.
His third voyage was conducted
at the request of King Manuel
of Portugal who was surely motivated
by the news of Amerigo's discovery
of lands east of the
Tordesillas meridian.
The expedition reportedly
lasted 16 months.
>> Filippo Camerota: So go back to
section four which is a collection
of maps produce before Waldseemuller
and after Waldseemuller.
This is useful just to learn which
kind of sources Waldseemuller had
at his disposal in order to build --
design his map and which kind
of [inaudible] we can see.
For example here, a map of
Martellus, and of course,
even here we have a very
interesting enlargement of the map,
and we can still rotate the
map, which is useful when names,
as I said, are written in
-- not in a horizontal line.
And after Waldseemuller
we have a lot of maps
which reproduce the shape of the
map, but also the name America.
This is Petrus Apianus.
This was the first map before the
discovering of that of Waldseemuller
who was known as the
one naming America.
But there are many
of them like this,
which is one of the most curious
maps of the Renaissance with a map
of Waldseemuller put
in the face of a fool.
But here, interestingly,
the name America is written
in the north part of the continent.
So it's shifted a little bit upward.
And just because in
this age they understood
that this also was a separate
continent and not a part
of Asia, as Columbus believed.
Other contemporary maps makes
different kind of projections.
The interesting things
with Waldseemuller is
that he was trying --
and actually he did --
to represent the entire surface
of the world, that is 360 degrees,
using a projection method that
was not described by Ptolemy,
because Ptolemy represented
only 180 degrees,
so 1/2 of the surface of the Earth.
And so several cartographers
in the same age were looking
for projection methods capable
to representing a flat
surface the entire Earth.
This is the case when, for example,
is useful to have these two here
because we had a lot of names
written in different lines.
And the globes, of course,
because after the one famous
of Martin Behaim, we find the --
which was painted on a globe
because the printing was not
yet the technique for
transmitting knowledge.
And with Waldseemuller we found
for the first time the way
to represent a sphere
through the gores this way.
And we have all the
different solutions,
or at least different images
developed by Waldseemuller
in the representation of this globe,
coming up to the Hunt-Lenux globe,
which is the first
representing, perhaps --
built in Florence in 1510,
representing America,
or at least the Mundus Novus in the
way Waldseemuller represented it.
From section five to section eight,
we enter a brief history
of cartography.
So the -- we have the Ancient
World with the story of Ptolemy,
before Ptolemy, and the
transmission of geography
with the "Cosmographiae."
We have the world discovered
and described by Marco Polo,
Niccolo de Conti, and other
travelers in the Middle Ages.
We have the routes to Indes, so the
Turkish blockade of Mediterranean,
and the project of the Portuguese.
These are all slideshow.
The Portuguese to circumnavigate
Africa, and then the New World
where we found an introduction
to Paolo dal Pozzo Toscanelli.
His letter was fundamental for
the project developed by Columbus.
We have the four voyages
by Christophorus Columbus,
the four voyages as I showed them
before of Vespucci, and a slideshow
on the political division of the
world with the Line of Tordesillas.
But I want to stop a
little bit on section nine,
because I think this is the most
interesting, the most innovative
in terms of educational
research activities.
We have here the problem of how
to represent the spherical surface
of the Earth on the flat surface.
So this is cartographic projection.
Ptolemy's projections and the
Waldseemuller projections,
and other cartographers'
projections are represented here
through 3-D animations, which
gives always the concept related
to the idea of that
principle's projections,
and the drawing method
-- how to draw it.
Ptolemy describes how to draw his
projection in the "Geographia,"
but reading that text is
quite difficult to follow him.
And these animations, I
think, give a good idea.
Let's see in this case only the
second projection of Ptolemy,
because this is the base
for Waldseemuller's map.
>> Ptolemy's second
cartographic method attempts
to reproduce an image
of the oikumene that is,
the inhabited world,
more closely resembling
that of the terrestrial globe,
giving the representation
a spherical appearance
that is almost totally
lacking in the first method.
While visually pleasing,
this concession adds nothing
as regards the measurability
of geographic coordinates,
a requirement already
fully satisfied
by the first cartographic method.
To obtain the desired effect,
Ptolemy imagines that he is looking
at the globe from a point
located exactly at the center
of the oikumene, not
only with respect
to the longitudinal amplitude
as in the first method,
but also with respect to
the latitudinal amplitude.
The viewpoint thus shifts from
the zenith of the Rhodes parallel
to that of the parallel passing
through Syene, modern Aswan,
situated precisely on
the Tropic of Cancer
at latitude 23 degrees
and 30 minutes north.
Next Ptolemy imagines a
representational plane tangent
to the point of intersection
between the central meridian
and the Syene parallel,
and he proceeds
to transfer the geographic
coordinates onto it.
As a result, the largest
circle tangent
to the representational
plane, and the orthogonal
to the central meridian -- in
other words, the ecliptic circle --
appears as a horizontal
straight line.
Such a circle does indeed
lie on a plane passing
through the observer's eye.
For the same optical reasons,
the central meridian will be seen
as a vertical straight line.
Because he needs to ensure
that distances are measurable,
Ptolemy marks the equal intervals of
five degrees on the horizontal line
that define the map's
longitudinal amplitude to the right
and the left of the
central meridian.
With the same intervals,
he then marks the latitudes
of the main parallel
circles on the central axis.
These are the equator, the
so-called anti-Meroe parallel,
and the Thule parallel.
As the equator intersects the
ecliptic circle at 90 degrees
from the central axis, it
will be shown on the plane
as an arc intersecting the
horizontal line at either end.
The other circles will appear
as arcs concentric to the first.
Their widths are defined
by the measurement
of the five-degree intervals,
which varies with latitude.
The center of the curvature
of the parallel arcs appears
on the central axis after tracing
the chord of the equatorial semi-arc
and the straight line orthogonal
to the center of the chord.
By joining the ends
of the parallel arc
with two curved lines
representing the zero-degree
and 180-degree meridians,
Ptolemy obtains the space
containing the map of the oikumene.
As in Ptolemy's first method,
the map is designed as a peel,
transferred from the
globe to the flat surface.
Ptolemy's second cartographic
method attempts to --
>> Filippo Camerota: And
now we see how to draw it.
>> To draw the map of the oikumene,
that is the inhabited world,
with the second cartographic
method, Ptolemy begins
by setting the boundaries
of the area to be drawn.
Tracing a rectangle whose width
is equal to twice its height,
the shorter side is divided into 90
parts corresponding to the degrees
of 1/4 of the Earth's meridian.
Starting from the bottom,
he then plots on the central
axis the points corresponding
to the parallels passing
through anti-Meroe,
the equator/Syene, and Thule.
Next he traces a horizontal
line passing
through the point corresponding
to Syene.
The line obtained represents
an image of the oblique circle
of the ecliptic as it
appears to the viewer.
The ecliptic looks like a straight
line because it lies on a plane
that is level with
the observer's eye.
The segment connecting the
equatorial point and the end
of the horizontal line is the chord
of the arc that, in this rendering,
denotes the circle of the equator.
The perpendicular drawn from the
center of the chord marks the center
of curvature of the equatorial
arc on the central axis.
Having found the center of this arc,
Ptolemy then draws the concentric
arcs representing the parallels,
passing through Thule,
Syene, and anti-Meroe.
Taking five units as a measurement
of the interval between meridians
on the equator, Ptolemy divides the
equatorial arc into 36 equal parts.
In other words, 180 units.
By means of a mathematical
calculation,
or using the more practical
solution of a terrestrial globe,
he then measures the value of the
same intervals on the Thule, Syene,
and anti-Meroe parallels.
To draw the meridians, he
constructs a series of arcs passing
through three points
chosen on the Thule, Syene,
and anti-Meroe parallels.
The outermost meridians
have a radius
of curvature easily
measured with a compass.
By contrast, the innermost meridians
approaching the straight line have a
very large radius, which
the cartographer was obliged
to measure with a string.
Unlike the parallels,
which are concentric arcs,
the meridians are arcs
whose curvature increases
from the center outward.
The central meridian, which
lies on the plane level
with the observer's eye,
appears to be a straight line.
Ptolemy interrupts his explanation
of the cartographic method
at this point, but the tables
illustrating the 15th-century
manuscripts of the
"Geography" clearly show
that the next step consisted
in drawing the parallels
every five degrees of latitude
or at variable latitudes.
This was the method used to fill out
the cartographic grid that served
as a guide for drawing
coastlines, cities,
mountain ranges, rivers, and lakes.
Colors, inscriptions,
depictions of winds,
and ornamental motifs
completed the pictorial
and cartographic representation
of the map of the oikumene.
>> Filippo Camerota: And now we come
to our map -- Waldseemuller's map.
>> Ptolemy's map represented only
a portion of the terrestrial glob,
the oikumene, that is, the
known, inhabited world.
In contrast, Waldseemuller's
map shows the entire surface
of the Earth except the southern
cap below the 44th parallel.
The Ptolemaic oikumene
is depicted at the center
of the map using Ptolemy's
second cartographic method,
which supplies the
geometric elements needed
to expand the drawing.
From a geometric standpoint,
Waldseemuller's map
is indeed an extension
of Ptolemy's second
cartographic method.
Beyond the boundaries of the ancient
world lie the remotest regions
of Asia described by Marco Polo
and the new World described
by Amerigo Vespucci.
Ptolemy's world and Vespucci's
world are illustrated separately
in the two small hemispheres
drawn at the top of the sheet,
next to the portraits of
the two cosmographers.
The Ptolemaic hemisphere coincides
with the central part of the map,
whereas Vespucci's hemisphere
is depicted in two halves,
one on the left, the
other on the right.
The top piece illustrates the lands
to the north of the parallel passing
through Thule, up to
the Arctic pole.
The map's overall aspect closely
resembles a solution developed
in the same period
by Leonardo da Vinci.
Unlike Ptolemy's --
>> Filippo Camerota:
Differently from Ptolemy's method
of drawing a map, which is
described in the geography,
for [inaudible] Waldseemuller
we don't have any information
about the procedure he used.
So this is just an
interpretation based on the map.
>> -- maps, Waldseemuller's
map showed the entire surface
of the globe.
To draw it, Waldseemuller
developed a geometric extension
of Ptolemy's second
cartographic method.
In doing so, he adopted the approach
proposed a few years earlier
by Henricus Matellus.
The geometric expansion was
suggested by Ptolemy's map itself,
on which the extension
of the meridian arcs indicated
a potential configuration
for the cartographic representation
north and south of the boundaries
of the oikumene, that
is, the inhabited world.
Having presumably followed this
indication, Waldseemuller marked,
on the central axis, the latitudes
of the Equator, the North Pole,
the Arctic Polar Circle,
and the last parallel chose
as the southern boundary, 40
degrees below the equator.
He then set a center of curvature
90 units from the North Pole,
slightly beyond the
center chose by Ptolemy,
and drew the main parallel arcs.
To plot the variable 10-degree
intervals on the parallels,
he chose the gore shapes used to
build the globe in solid form.
The German cartographer then took
a reduction compass and set it
to a ratio of one to eight,
which is the size ratio
of the gores to the map.
He measured the intervals on the
equator, on the Polar Circle,
and on the last southern parallel,
plotting them on the
corresponding arcs on the map.
Next he drew two intermediate
parallels,
one passing through the city of
Syene, 23 degrees and 30 minutes
above the equator, and one situated
at 20 degrees below the equator.
He subdivided these
parallels, like the others,
into 10-degree intervals.
He could now trace the meridian
arcs above and below the equator,
constructing them as curves
intersecting three points.
As in Ptolemy's first
cartographic method,
each arc was split at the equator.
To build the meridian arcs north
of the Arctic Polar Circle,
Waldseemuller seems to have chosen
a laborious geometric construction.
He began by tracing the chord
of the outermost meridian arc,
making it end a short
distance above the North Pole,
so as to obtain a horizontal line.
On this line he drew an equilateral
triangle positioned in such a way
that its vertex serves as the center
of curvature of the meridian arc.
He then traced the chord
of the meridian arc closest
to the central axis, and placed
the center of the curvature
at the intersection between the
line perpendicular to the chord
and the horizontal line passing
through the first center
of curvature.
The horizontal line thus became the
location of the centers of curvature
of all the other meridian arcs.
He then drew the chords of all the
meridian arcs, marked the center
of each chord on an arc
passing through the center
of the first two chords, traced
the respective perpendicular lines,
and marked the centers of curvature
of the meridian arcs
on the horizontal line.
The final step in the
geometric construction
of the world map consisted in
drawing the meridian arcs north
of the Arctic Polar Circle.
On this cartographic grid,
Waldseemuller drew the profiles
of lands, perhaps starting
with Ptolemy's oikumene,
which the German cartographer
reproduced
with no geographic updates.
He then drew the lands of the Far
East, up to the modern-day Japan,
and the southern reaches of Africa,
circumnavigated by the Portuguese.
Lastly, he drew the coasts of
the New World using information
from Spanish and Portuguese
mapmakers.
He completed the drawing by
marking cities, rivers, mountains,
and winds, and by inserting a
wealth of text information --
all enclosed in an
exquisite ornamental frame.
The printing process was no less
complex, given the size of the map.
Waldseemuller divided
the sheet into 12 parts,
adopting a simple geometric
construction using diagonals
or dividing the two sides of
the image in three and in four.
He cut the entire sheet
into 12 smaller sheets
and engraved a separate
woodblock for each.
To transfer the image to the block,
he presumably used
the dusting method,
perforating the entire
drawing with a punch.
He then placed the sheet on
the woodblock facing down
and transferred the drawing by means
of a pad coated with colored powder,
so as to leave the trace of the
image in reverse on the wood.
Now an engraver set to work,
removing the wood from all the parts
of the drawing that were to
remain white in the final print.
When the carving was complete, the
woodblock was inked and pressed
against a sheet of printing paper.
And so the 12 prints were
assembled to form the world map
that gave its name to America.
>> Filippo Camerota: It was
an immense work, no doubt.
And we can see also the globe
because this is the first time
we find a globe drawn this way
with the gores.
>> The meridians and parallels
that by convention define the
geographic coordinates of places
on the surfaces of the Earth
can be grouped together
into 12 shapes called gores, each
covering 30 degrees in longitude.
If we imagine that we could peel
the Earth as we would an orange,
we can lay the gores
flat on a plane surface,
forming a map that is discontinuous,
but free of distortions.
This method made it
possible to draw, print,
and construct a terrestrial
globe by pasting the 12 gores
onto the solid surface of a sphere.
To draw the gores that
compose the terrestrial globe,
the mapmaker starts by drawing
the line of the equator,
on which all the degrees
of longitude are marked
at equal intervals.
Thirty-six intervals of 10 degrees
each form the entire circumference
of the Earth.
By convention, each gore is
30 degrees wide and is bounded
by to arcs of a circle with a
radius equal to 270 degrees.
Inside each gore, the mapmaker
draws two other arcs passing
through the poles of the
intermediate meridians.
By dividing each arc into equal
parts representing intervals
of 10 degrees, the mapmaker
obtains a series of points that,
once connected horizontally, make it
possible to draw all the parallels.
By transferring the
geographic coordinates of places
onto this cartographic grid,
the mapmaker can draw the
Earth's entire surface on a plane,
which will assume a spherical shape
only after attaching the gores
to the surface of a globe.
>> Filippo Camerota: Here there is
a section which answers, I think,
to one of the questions
made yesterday
about the extension of the world.
We have a comparison
between the world of Ptolemy
and the actual world, actually.
The world of Ptolemy was
smaller than the real one.
We can see that the world of Ptolemy
actually covered only 120 degrees
on the surface of the Earth.
And we can see the Fra Mauro's
world, which is still based
on the dimensions of the Ptolemy's
world, but it's a little bit bigger
because there is the -- part of
Asia described by Marco Polo.
And Columbus' world, still same
size with the missing part,
which was that -- the one which
would have made a difference
if he would have known that
there was such a long distance
between Portugal or the
[inaudible] islands and Japan.
Actually this was the distance
estimated by Toscanelli and Colombo,
and this is the real distance.
And then Vespucci's world,
which is a little bit bigger,
just because includes the new
lands discovered on the ocean --
Atlantic ocean, but you can
see here Japan is very close
to the North American, actually is
on the same place of California.
And the section 10 is
devoted to the ocean.
And then here we find the Carta
marina, which we can explore more
or less in the same way we did
with the world map,
enlarging it as we wish.
And the resolution is very big
thanks to the files produced
by the Library of Congress.
And even here we have the
concept and the drawing --
the drawing map of the Carta marina.
>> The sea chart is a transformation
of the spherical surface
of the terrestrial globe onto a
plane surface that we can imagine
as being tangent to the
point of intersection
between the meridian
and the equator.
The transformation is performed
by transferring the meridians
and parallels onto a cylinder that
surrounds the terrestrial globe
and is then developed
onto a plane surface.
After the transformation,
the meridians
and parallels form an
orthogonal grid divided
into regular intervals
of equal size.
However, while the length of
the meridians remains unchanged
with respect to their length
measured on the globe,
the length of the parallels
increases as one moves
from the equator to the poles.
The advantage of this
cartographic transformation is that,
while altering the
measurement of longitude,
it preserves the orthogonal
intersections between meridians
and parallels, as on
the terrestrial globe.
In consequence, any given
oblique line showing a direction
of the wind rose will always
meet the meridians and parallels
at the same angle, exactly as it
does on the terrestrial globe.
This is clearly an advantage
for plotting navigation routes.
To prepare the sea chart,
the cartographer begins
by drawing a rectangle
twice as wide as high.
He then plots the two
central axes and divides them
into equal intervals,
18 on the vertical axis
and 36 on the horizontal.
Next, he draws the entire grid
of meridians and parallels.
Waldseemuller confined his
attention to the section
of the grid extending
240 degrees in longitude
between latitude 70 degrees
north latitude 50 degrees south.
The grid is only a
construction diagram
and so does not appear
on the actual map.
Waldseemuller then traced a circle
with a radius equal
to the vertical --
>> Filippo Camerota: I stop it
here because the time is gone.
And just to give you some more
information, we have a section
on the sky, too, so astronomical
instruments for navigations.
And there are a lot
of slideshows here
and animations giving
the instructions of how
to use instruments for navigating.
And then the last chapter is devoted
to the digital library with a list
of books, books related to
the production of the maps
of Waldseemuller, of course,
and the maps which are more
or less the same maps we
have seen in section four.
And I think this is all,
and the website is online,
so you can continue by yourself.
Thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: So you can see
there is a lot of content here.
It would take about, I don't
know, 14 hours to actually go
through the entire website if
you were to watch everything.
Obviously there was a lot of time
and a lot of argument about how
to look at these things as
the website was developed,
but you can see that it is
now out there for the world.
I would invite Filippo
and Paolo to come up.
If people have any
questions we can answer them.
>> That is --
>> John Hessler: Thanks.
>> When you began the project did
you envision as vast as it ended up?
>> Filippo Camerota: No, no.
Not at all.
It was something that
was developed in time.
This is why I said before that I
consider myself as a filmmaker.
This is not my profession, but
in this case this was the change
in my way to work that it happened.
I started as a scholar just giving
text to the graphic designers,
and then I realized that in order
to make these kind of things I had
to be there with the
graphic designers
and work with them every day.
And fortunately we have
a multimedia laboratory
in our museum, in our institution.
And it's easier to work with
people who are accustomed
to understand these kinds of topics.
But of course, it was
not visible before.
>> John Hessler: It hasn't
stopped growing, either.
There's going to be additions
to it as the page turner
for the actual [inaudible].
And now we're talking
about the Carta marina.
And so it's not -- it's an
obsession that will not end.
>> Paolo Galluzzi: And it is
very important also to consider
that after this first huge
step you should imagine
that this becomes a
research environment --
collective research environment
where we would make space
for interaction from users.
And eventually also having a site
where they can publish
their comments,
being registered before, of course.
And so they can grow this archive
and keeping it updated thanks
to the users' contribution.
That will not be all kids.
Will be scholars who will use these,
and will have something to say,
and would be nice to have that
embedded into the website.
>> John Hessler: One additional
thing I think I want to show,
just since the website
is back up here.
And I think --
-- one of the most
interesting things about --
oops, that's not the one.
One of the things that
people always want to know
about is astronomical instruments,
and navigation instruments
and how they work.
So for instance, there
are videos in here
which basically show how all
the different navigational
instruments work.
All 3-D animations, and basically a
nocturnal astro lab, the quadrant,
the nautical astro lab, all
of this stuff is animated.
And I think it's one of the
most important parts of the --
outside of the construction of the
Waldseemuller map, I think it's one
of the most important
additions because these --
this is always a question
many, many people ask.
So I just wanted to show that
because we didn't get to it, so.
>> How long was this project --
>> John Hessler: How long?
>> So when did this project start?
>> Paolo Galluzzi:
[Inaudible] Sorry.
>> John Hessler: Just leave it on.
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Slightly less
than three years, I would say.
Huh? Do you think so?
Filippo has --
>> Filippo Camerota: More or less.
>> Actually from this is -- for this
methodology [inaudible] resource
used [inaudible] the Library
[inaudible] it must be [inaudible]
resource could apply any other topic
in the Museum or in the Library.
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Absolutely.
>> Is any intention to do that
otherwise, or the resource?
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Yeah,
I think this is a way --
the right way of concept
that we call general just the
Library is two old friends
in a very passive and limited way.
And digital library means creating
environment where not only books,
manuscripts, but images,
stories told by contemporary
graphic computers, documents,
objects are all linked
together, as have been linked
through the development of
history, but have been separated
in different institutions for
preservation reasons basically.
Now you have this chance to
forgetting the preservation concerns
and linking again data that are
linked intrinsically like that.
So this is, as you
suggested, is a model.
You can add these two as many
chart -- maps as you want.
But not only maps.
I showed before the
Galileo Teca, which is a way
of creating a research
environment with all the material
that scholars use when
they study on Galileo.
We're doing the same
with the Leonardo Teca.
And I think it is the way
in which the revolution --
huge revolution which just happened
with the digital technology,
and there's nothing --
I mean, Gutenberg Galaxy was nothing
compared what has happened now.
Has to be exploited, and so this
is the reason why you need models.
You need to try to find
ways of organizing documents
and knowledge in a different way.
>> John Hessler: Yeah,
the last square
on this is called the digital
library, and in that are all
of the books and all of
the maps that were used
in a more traditional forum, so
you can click on one of the books
and a page turner comes up.
So all the sort of
traditional sources are
in that last section, too.
So for scholars who want to
actually look through every one
of these books, every one of the
books that went into this website,
and every one of the
maps is fully digitized
in high resolution in that backend.
But it really is a model.
>> John, I see that the -- by the
icon, I believe, on the top right,
that the site is also
available in Italian language.
Are there any plans to
add any other languages
like Spanish, French, etcetera?
>> John Hessler: Do you
feel like translating?
>> No. I'm just looking
at the wider population
that could have a great
interest in this.
>> John Hessler: Yeah.
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Yeah, it is
certainly important would be
at least Spanish language.
At the moment our energy
is exhausted for --
and I also the financial
resources are exhausted.
And we have to find partners.
We are absolutely open.
In the book that has been published
and that you will have
soon copies available,
we have provided also
Portuguese and Spanish translation
because we are perfectly aware that
these are two worlds in which --
through which we have to talk to.
Laura.
>> I'm sort of interested in
the fact you have used a map
to have a multidisciplinary
explanation of an awful lot
of things that have to do with
maps, but it becomes [inaudible].
The technology you have could be
used to achieve a dream that I have,
which is to see whether we can't
take the Mediterranean Basin,
take maps, and draw
25-year histograms,
building up from what happened
from [inaudible] right on up
to what happened in the Second World
War, using the map as the focus
to let people probe more deeply into
any subject of historical interest
in any part of that Basin.
It's -- it is our cradle
for most of civilization.
But the technology that you have,
if it's not continued to be used,
I hope you don't lose it.
I hope somebody picks it up and sort
of takes it beyond where you have
to do things along the idea of that.
Of course, it takes money, but it's
a wonderful way to just sort of lay
out a broad range of disciplines.
>> Filippo Camerota: As you know,
technology changes very quickly,
so we have to follow the -- this
path, and then, yeah, all right.
>> John Hessler: The thing
about this is what you see
here is what can be achieved
when you place scholars next
to an in-house multimedia,
really talented, but very small
development team, and you lock the
in a room, and you
basically bang ideas around,
and around, and around, and around.
And that's the model here.
And the Galileo Museum is
so perfectly suited
to this kind of work.
It is really a model for how
to do the digital humanities.
There is no question about it.
When you take a thing like this,
you're not just throwing this
masterpiece of cartography up there
and saying, "Well, here's a
masterpiece of cartography."
We're doing very much what
say Joaquim Gaspar called
for in his talk yesterday, that
you can't just look at this
as just a map, as some
geographical thing.
There is so much culture and
science embedded in this document.
And it is a way to teach the
history of science through images.
And it is the modern digital
humanities at its absolute best.
And so that's really what -- well,
at least that's what I think it is.
I'm, of course, biased, but --
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Well,
I think that you touched
upon a very important point
which is the cohabitation of
developers of informatics programs
and software, and scholars,
and people who have idea
what should be communicated.
This is very rare still
in our world.
And as I stressed in my -- initially
the remarks is one of the privileges
of this institution, we are
right at the point in which 1/3
of our budget goes in IT.
And 1/3 of our personnel
is IT person.
And this is a challenge that
we -- I mean, taking risk,
but I think is going to pay.
>> John Hessler: And those
animations that you saw,
like the Waldseemuller
drawing animations, that --
those speculative tools
that you can use
to show people how this map might
have been drawn, we could stand
up here and give papers
all day about, you know,
with little PowerPoint presentations
about how that was drawn,
but it doesn't show you it
the way it shows you here.
I mean, you get a real sense
of the complexity and the tools
that were necessary
to make this map.
I mean, you really walk away -- and
like I said, there is 14 hours --
I don't know how long it
would take you to look
through this entire thing.
I haven't -- you know, it's weeks.
There's so much imbedded
information in here.
But any other questions or?
Laura.
>> Yes.
>> John Hessler: By the way,
Laura Campbell, who is sitting
in the front row -- or
second row here was really --
when she was the head of OSI,
which is the Officers
Strategic Initiatives,
she was really responsible for
putting the Galileo Museum in touch
with the Geography and Map Division.
And really she deserves
credit, as she says, for --
she doesn't want to
take much credit,
but for opening the door, so.
>> [Applause] Thank you very much.
Congratulations.
You have achieved that
vision from --
geez, it was every bit
of three years ago.
If you -- in looking back --
I know once you got into this
development it was a small
and exceptionally bright
group that you worked with.
Do you have any kind of lessons
about undertaking something
like this for the people here?
>> Paolo Galluzzi: I do not here,
of course, but I'm always stressing
that the digital humanities
is quite serious stuff,
and quite challenging.
It's a place of competition,
of new competition among
cultural institutions.
And maybe the assets have been
established in number of volumes,
or number of items, or might
be totally overturned once
that you enter the web where
you may have no [inaudible]
but might be much more in
impact than huge institution.
The passage, as has been said before
by John -- I totally subscribe --
is that you need to have inside
the institution a group of people
that dialogue every day with that
producer of content, and adapt,
try it, make first trial, correct,
and arrive at the final
good solution.
This is very uncommon yet, I guess
I don't know the situation here,
of course, but in Europe and in my
country especially, I can think say
that we are the only
cultural institution
in which we have this situation.
I don't think there is a second one.
And I believe that this is
a key passage if you want
to find digital humanities
becoming an engine
that is producing --
attract interest.
We give life to a declining
interest in the humanities
and also a powerful teaching tool.
Powerful.
>> John Hessler: Yeah,
we tested the --
this with the Teachers'
Institute here, and --
this summer in its
not-quite-finished form.
And they do a section
on Waldseemuller
as a primary source teaching tool.
And they were just -- you know,
this was just an amazing --
even some of the teachers took it
back, and there's several teachers
in Missouri and Nebraska
who at the beginning
of the semester had them
using it on high primary
and early high school students.
And it is just working
out phenomenally.
And so now that it's been
launched it can be used anywhere.
But I think it's -- that's
where its primary thing will be.
But also, not everyone --
there's a lot of historians
of cartography in this
room right here.
I bet you I could take maybe
two or three who would be able
to tell me how Ptolemy
drew his projection.
You know, maybe Joaquim would
be able to actually do it
with a compass, but otherwise
it's pretty much not well-known.
>> Filippo Camerota: I have to say
that this happened actually when one
of the historians of cartography
came to us and saw these animations.
I don't [inaudible]
he commented, "Yeah,
finally I understand what
Ptolemy had in mind."
Not because it's --
yeah, this is the truth,
when you read the text
you imagine something,
but it's not exactly
what is written there.
If you see something translated
in images you have a better idea,
of course, if the translation
is made by people
who are accustomed
to work with images.
I was trained as an architect.
This is why I could
do this kind of job.
I think it's not common to do this
if you don't know geometrical
projections because, of course,
you need that kind of
preparation in order
to explain graphically
something which is only written,
like in the book of Waldseemuller.
>> John Hessler: Yeah, in my rare
book school class I have my students
sit and actually draw
the second projection
with a string and a compass.
And you know, it's
just forcing people
to do geometry and
that sort of thing.
And this is just -- I think
it's an amazing resource, so.
>> Paolo Galluzzi: As a question
that has been raised about the model
that we mentioned before,
I think that those
who yesterday heard Dava
Sobel giving the lecture,
of course one field in which you
might immediately translate the
structure is celestial
cartography, obviously.
You take the solarios or you
take the famous maps of crowded
with information with a cipher
for common people, and
you can decode that.
And usually it's actually
the same structure
because there are observational
instruments,
measurement instruments behind.
So it's very much -- I
insist on that -- a model.
May be a wrong model.
May be certainly an improved --
improvable model, but is a model
that I hope will be used
for many other things.
>> John Hessler: And I guess we
could take one more question.
Or if Laura, you have
another comment or --
>> Oh.
>> John Hessler: --
Stephanie, go ahead.
>> Yeah, oh, thank you.
I just want to start by saying I've
been involved in digital humanities
from when it was called
humanities computing in the 1990s,
and so I've seen a lot of projects.
I direct a center -- a digital
humanities center, and I just want
to say how astonishingly excellent
this is, and also to thank you
for the gift that this is,
being open access to the world
of learners and scholars.
And then just to jump to one
little question, I -- in our --
some of our projects now
we're trying to explore how
to make transparent the
scholarly process of debate
and controversy, interpretation.
I'm wondering if your site does
that, or if you hope to do that,
to have different scholars weighing
in and debating, or publishing some
of their interpretations?
>> Paolo Galluzzi: Well, that's --
next time we will give a look to the
-- better look to the Galileo Teca,
which I gave you few slides before,
which is online already,
so you can use it.
And in that application we have
tried to answer your problem.
Any user can store in the
system its own comments,
can even publish a paper inside.
And this means that
around a [inaudible]
of the application you have
people who have come in and said,
"I don't think it's right.
I think that your interpretation
has to -- should be changed."
And this is growing with the
archive and will be available
for all the users who come after
you have stored your remarks.
And this is making a living engine,
these things, because the risk
of this kind of application,
this technology becomes
so quickly obsolete.
Information is growing.
And all the weight of keeping it --
that updated is to make a
community tool of this tool.
And so we will certainly work
on that aspect in the future,
even or this Waldseemuller website.
>> John Hessler: Well,
thank you both.
And move on to our last
talk of the conference.
[ Applause ]
Well, I hope you all go home
and perhaps get some sort
of large takeout and some sort of
large supply of alcoholic beverages
and play with the website for the
rest of the [laughter] weekend.
Our last talk of the
conference, there's a --
one of the most unappreciated or
unseen divisions here at the Library
of Congress is the
Conservation Division.
They work pretty much behind the
scenes, but they are really critical
to every single thing
that we do here.
It is a small team of
extremely talented,
extremely dedicated
scientists/artist/curators all
molded into one place.
And this afternoon
we're going to hear --
or this morning we're
going to hear a short talk
by the Chief Conservator at the
Library of Congress, Elmer Eusman,
about what it really took to encase
and preserve the Waldseemuller
1507 map as it is displayed
in the galleries upstairs.
When you walk up to that case,
there is a huge amount of technology
that is sitting behind
that case, that keeps it --
that map as it is and allows us to
keep it on permanent exhibition.
Elmer has done conservation
on paper.
He's a paper conservator
by training.
He's worked at museums all over
the world, from the Rijksmuseum,
to the Metropolitan Museum of
Art, to the National Gallery.
He's worked on prints from the
Renaissance, which is his specialty.
So without further ado,
I give you Elmer Eusman.
[ Applause ]
>> Elmer Eusman: Thank you, John,
for that very kind introduction.
And gosh, thank you for setting me
up, because I'm going to be the guy
with the simple PowerPoint, so
I'm sorry for that [laughter].
We are Conservation, after all.
So making the case,
sealing the deal.
Making the case, not only literally
making the case in which we're going
to be displaying and storing the
map, we're also arguing for the fact
that this is what we need to do.
Sealing the deal, as in
we're going to seal the map
in an hermetically-sealed case,
but also as the last station
in what was sometimes an arduous
process in the Library's ability
to finally acquire the map.
So I thought that was
pretty clever [laughter].
Okay, all right, moving on.
So as John said, when you visit the
Library's northwest pavilion and go
through the Exploring the
Early Americas exhibit,
you will find at the very
back end the Carta marina
and the Waldseemuller map
displayed right next to one another.
And for all intents and purposes,
that is exactly the same setup
for both, same display
case, same low light level.
The big difference is that
one of them has a big amount
of technology behind it, and that is
because in this case the
Waldseemuller map is the real one.
The Carta marina is a facsimile.
And so as John also said, this
gives me great opportunity
to talk a little bit about
what transpired and the work
that went into it to get us there.
It was three years' work of work.
So let me first quickly share
with you why we did what we did.
So I don't have to tell you
the importance of the map.
I don't think -- or that was
well covered yesterday and today.
But there were some additional
directions, if you will.
The U.S. Congress provided about 1/2
of the purchase price of the map,
so they were a big stakeholder.
The German government was also a
big stakeholder because they needed
to be willing to provide
export license for the map
to actually come to
the United States.
And both these institutions
expressed a desire to make the map
as widely accessible as possible.
So that's an important concept,
all right, want to share the map.
That does not make
Conservation always very happy.
So now we're in the classic dilemma
between access and preservation.
So the main problem with display is
the accumulated damage from light.
So light transfers energy to matter.
And the higher frequency,
the smaller the wavelength,
the higher the energy,
more damage is being done.
Ultraviolet light does more damage
to artifacts than regular light.
Think of your newspaper in sunlight.
That's the idea.
That's what we want to avoid.
And that's easy to do.
We can filter UV light
out fairly comfortably.
But even regular light
will still do damage.
So we want to take that out as well,
but then we can't see
anything, so that doesn't work.
Lucky for us oxygen plays a
critical role in this process.
It's a photolythic
oxidation process.
So it stands to reason that if we
take oxygen out of the equation,
then we have a little bit
more liberty in trying to see
if we can do something
for a long-term display.
A long-term display
is really anything
that is something beyond six months.
Most things, traveling
exhibits, we usually try
to aim for about three months.
So we are here in our 10th year,
so we're really talking
long-term display here.
We do have two strategies
here at the Library,
and that is we have cooled cases.
For those of you who have already
walked through the Great Hall,
you will see there are two
Bibles, the Gutenberg Bible
and the Giant Bible of Mainz.
Those are slightly different cases.
Those are cooled to about
50 degrees Fahrenheit.
And the concept there is we
slow down degradation mechanisms
in general by cooler temperature.
But we have the ability to do that
because we have multivolume Bibles
that can be interchanged,
and we can also change pages.
That was not going to be an option
for the map, and so we really wanted
to pursue this oxygen-free,
hermetically-sealed case.
So that's great, except we
don't have that technology here.
Actually, we didn't
have that 10 years ago.
Lucky for us there was a government
institution not too far away,
Gettysburg just outside the
District, called National Institute
for Standards and Technology.
And they had just done the very
thing for the Charters of Freedom
at the National Archives
and Record Administration.
Charters of Freedom include
the U.S. Constitution,
Declaration of Independence.
And they had just wrapped up
this project to replace the --
I think they were originally built
in the '50s, these encasements,
and they made brand-new cases.
Unfortunately for us, a lot
of these members that worked
on that project had retired by now,
but we could still snag one or two
of them, and they were instrumental
in helping us build these cases.
So we have the map.
We have stakeholders who
really want this to happen.
We have Conservation willing to
work on this, and the one thing
that we're missing is
funding to do this project.
And that happened in the generous
donation by Ms. Virginia Grey
and the Grey Family who established
the Waldseemuller Support Fund
in honor and memory of Martin Grey.
There were additional sponsors
and additional donations,
but it's safe to say that
without the Grey Family,
this case would not have been built.
All right, so an hermetically-sealed
case has several challenges.
I'm going to try to
explain this a little bit.
Hermetically-sealed really
means no air goes in and out.
And as most of you
know, air will expand
or gasses will expand
when temperature rises.
And gases inside the
hermetically-sealed case will be
affected by barometric pressures.
A low pressure system will allow an
hermetically-sealed case to expand,
and a high pressure system
will do the exact opposite.
So both temperature and barometric
pressure are a critical player
in this.
If the pressure or the
pressures combined get too much,
the seal will break.
And the whole notion
is that the seal needs
to stay intact to keep
the oxygen out.
So the case has to be able
to withstand these pressures
and has enough flexibility
to do that.
SO that was the first thing.
It was great that NARA -- or that
NIST and NARA could work together
on the Charters of Freedom, but
they were nowhere near the size
of map we're talking about here.
We're talking about
about 50 square feet.
We're talking about an
encasement of more than 400 liters.
And this completely dwarfs anything
they had worked with with NARA.
Another challenge was the fact
that we could not use the same
seals that were used in NARA.
In NARA they used metal
seals -- metal O-ring seals.
And for those seals to
work, an inordinate amount
of pressure needs to be applied.
That pressure will also be put upon
the glass that is right in front
of the case, and makes
the glass crack.
That already happened
with the smaller cases.
With a larger case like this one,
this was simply not an option.
So this needed to be
thought through.
Let me see, yeah, I cannot
stress enough that the size
of this case is -- was
going to be enormous.
So great, we have a metal
box with a piece of glass
in front of it, and it's sealed.
So how are we actually going
to mount a map inside
of that and secure it?
That was another question.
And then the last item is
how are we actually going
to monitor the conditions
inside the case?
So we need to look
at the oxygen levels.
We need to look at the temperature.
We need to look at
the relative humidity.
And again, we need to look at what
we call the differential pressure,
that is the amount of
pressure inside the case.
This is going to be a key component
because we don't want the pressures
to go over a certain
threshold, and we lose the seal.
How do you add all these
components and not add more factors
that could make for a leaky case?
Any time you put a sensor
in this case you create
another potential opening
or a seal that can break.
So complicated matter.
A lot to do, but at
the end of the day
as a project manager we only
have one goal, how do we design,
fabricate, test, and install this
exhibit case with the map inside?
That's the goal.
There were additional objectives.
There were a number of
scientific, conservation,
but also really purely project
management considerations.
And I just mentioned the last
one I think is always important
when you do this sort of
stuff, how do you make sure
that every team member
not only feels involved,
but by the time the project is
done not everybody is so stressed
out that they're tearing
their hair out and just want
to run away as quickly as possible?
You know, make -- manage your
project carefully basically.
So one of the first steps is
to determine what are the
requirements for this case?
So we already talked about
a number of these things.
It needs to be, of
course, structurally sound,
not for obvious reasons like we
need to be able to transport it.
Cannot build it here.
It has to be built elsewhere.
So it needs to be structurally
sound.
But it also needs to be
structurally sound that it, again,
can withstand these pressures.
If we can -- tiny cracks or
hairline fractures, again,
we're going to lose the seal, and
that would not be the right thing.
We need to, at least
as a requirement,
we said keep the oxygen level below
0.1%, and we need to have that --
we need to keep that
environment for at least 10 years.
This is going to be a big operation,
and we want to make
sure we don't have
to do it more than every 10 years.
Needs to withstand
atmospheric pressure changes.
It needs to be as light as possible.
At the time when we started the
project in the fall of 2004,
we did not know where this
encasement was going to be located.
So it could be in any of the
three Capital campus buildings.
Could be in the Jefferson
building, as it turns out.
And then we are highly constrained
with how much weight we
can put on the floors.
So light, we need to be able to
fit it through wherever it's going
to come through, and then we need to
put the map in an upright position.
And just think about the
size map that we have.
We're going to make a
metal case around this map,
and we do that in a flat position.
So how are we going to get it
upright, and keep it that way,
and have it -- and do
that in a secure way?
So couple of starting
points, the case we're going
to make is not going
to contain any welding.
This is not going to make for
a structurally sound case.
This -- with the pressures
involved that was not the avenue
that NIST wanted to pursue.
No bellows.
So bellows are a method to
account for the pressures
that this case is going
to be withstanding.
So it's basically a balloon or a
series of balloons that are attached
to the encasement, and
any time the gas expands,
some of that excess air goes in
the balloon versus the encasement.
There's some problems
with the bellows systems.
They're finicky, they're
hard to maintain,
and they might not always perform
as well as we would like to do.
So NIST really wanted to
step away from that and say,
"We're not going to do that.
We're going to actually build a
case that's going to have the bottom
so thin that it will
actually be flexible enough."
So consider a metal bottom that's
going to be flexible enough.
And will show you in a
second how that works.
And then, as I said, the metal
O-rings are not going to work,
so we're going to use two
O-ring -- Viton O-ring seals.
And I'll show you how that works.
Viton is a synthesized rubber used
in the aeronautic industry as well.
And for our purpose really perfect.
So I'm going to show you a series
of drawings that will give you a bit
of an indication of, you know,
what the makeup of the case is.
So at the top -- and I have my
handy-dandy laser pointer here,
sorry.
Here we go.
So at the top here you see
the encasement from the side.
So we have over here
the encasement bottom.
And this is the frame that will
hold the glass that goes on top.
So you see the whole
package from the side.
Here at the bottom I've sort
of blown it up a little --
you know, opened it up a little bit.
You can see a crosscut of what
I -- the encasement bottom.
Then right on top of
that is the platform.
The platform will eventually
hold the map.
On top of that the glass,
and on top of that the frame.
Okay, so this is highly schematic.
I'm going to focus on this
portion of the encasement.
So keep this shape in mind.
So as I said, we were
not going to do welding.
Instead we're going to take a
monolithic block of aluminum alloy,
and we're going to mill it down to
the shape in which we want to --
the shape that we want to create.
So this monolithic block of
aluminum alloy was actually donated
to us by Alcoa.
And well, you see the size there.
This -- I'm going to
make a comparison here.
This is about 256 gallons
of milk, or a mid-size car.
That is the size of aluminum block
we're talking about here, okay.
And so what we're going to
do, we're going to mill this
into the shape that we desire.
And on the right side you can
actually see how the platform was
milled at NIST.
So the milling of the bottom
that I showed you earlier --
and that is the big block --
was actually done a t Bechdon,
which is -- Bechdon is just
outside Washington, DC as well.
And they shaped that.
But at least you get a little bit
of a feel of the size of the project
or the size of the case,
because that is the platform.
What they're milling in this
platform -- which is a relatively,
you know, thin sheet
of aluminum alloy --
and what they're milling there
is little weight-saving pockets.
So the structure of the
platform stays intact,
but you scrape away excess weight.
So some serious excess
weight was scraped away
by the end of the process.
So I hope you can see that we're
getting to that shape that I pointed
out earlier -- of the main block
that we talked about earlier.
So that was about, you know,
more than 90% of the block
has been scraped away.
I was thinking about
that last night.
I thought, "Gosh, they must really
have a good recycling program there,
because that's a lot of aluminum."
And what you see from the side
here are two of the grooves
where the O-ring seals
will be positioned.
And I'll talk about that
center channel in a second.
And you can see the channels
here from the top, okay.
And you can also see how the --
how a lot of the aluminum was
scraped away here, and you get sort
of that rib structure on the side.
So this makes for a
really rigid structure
without having the
weight needed to do that.
So then we have to have
a little bit of bulk here
to keep the structure intact.
And then here we have
that flexible bottom.
So if that four-inch aluminum
block has been scraped
down all the way to 1/4 inch.
And that 1/4 inch -- and
because the encasement is
so big will actually flex up
to about an inch in the center.
So that's how much
aluminum can flex.
So then in this picture what
we're showing is the next step,
and that is the platform.
And on the platform we will
have two carefully-selected
and tested cellulose boards, and on
top of that we will place the map.
So you can see here the Japanese
paper hinges that we're using
with wheat starch paste
to mount the map.
The map is then so hinged to
the board, and the board --
see, here's the platform.
The board is actually
two layers of board.
The screw goes through the
first one at the bottom one,
and the top one we
make careful incisions,
and we lift a little flap off
the board, screw both layers in,
and then put the flap back.
So this way none of
the screws will --
or any metal, for that
matter, will touch the map.
So then the next step
is to put the seals in.
So these are long, you know, almost
O-ring rubber bands if you will.
You can see here Richard
DeGore [assumed spelling]
and AnnLinn Kruger, one
of Conservation staff,
and DeGore was one of the
main engineers from NIST,
carefully threading these seals
into the top of the bottom.
And here they're sort of placed.
And then the next step is
to actually put the glass
on top of the whole thing.
So the glass was held by the frame.
And then the way NIST figured this
out was to put little Teflon clips
to -- dozens of them
-- around the perimeter
of the frame that holds the glass.
And when the glass goes down
it will rest on the seals.
And this is why this
hole is right there,
because that will hold
the Teflon clips.
This center channel will be used
to actually do leak testing,
because what we're going to do,
we're going to push helium
gas into this channel.
And we have a leak detector,
and whenever helium is detected,
it will tell us whether the
seal is actually working or not.
All right, sorry, let
me just quickly go back.
So I cannot really see this very
well, but I think this is NIST
and their workshop in which
they did most of the testing.
And I now also see this picture
-- this is sort of interesting,
you know, the problems you run
into during this type of project.
So the glass broke
in two ways on us.
First of all, it was very kind
of Solutia to donate the glass,
but it arrived in a nailed-together
A-frame, and by the time it arrived
at NIST, seven of the nine
sheets had completely fallen
over in the truck and
were completely useless.
And the two that were left
had already little nicks
and so were also useless,
because you cannot have any --
like the smallest nick
in this glass.
So we had to ask, "Well,
that's great,
but could you send us
another couple of these?"
And they very kindly did.
And then at NIST we actually also
broke another sheet of glass,
again because the bolts
that I will talk
about in a second had
been too tight,
and so it was a little finicky.
The glass, by the way, is what
we call hurricane-proof glass.
It is a laminated sheet.
So there's two layers of glass
with a laminated layer in between.
So also able to withstand
quite some pressure.
So this is then what
the profile looks like.
So we have the encasement bottom.
We have the platform with the map.
The platform is secured with
what we call a trim bar.
So that's -- that secures
the platform.
The glass goes on top
with the frame.
And you can see that the gas inside
would have to pass these two seals
in order to, you know,
have any air exchange
with the ambient air outside.
So these are the two seals
that really make the
case hermetically sealed.
So then what do we need to do?
Well, we need to bolt
it all together.
So there's 92 bolts that go
around the perimeter of the map.
And then we have to
have two ports for gases
to be introduced into the system.
So one for the helium
channel I explained earlier,
and this is for the main chamber.
And these main chambers --
I should have drawn this,
but the main chamber, they are
communicated to one another,
so there's not two chambers here.
There's really one.
So that is not -- in principle
that's sort of the same way
that we -- that NIST
did this at NARA.
Our challenge, again, was of
course the pure size of the thing.
So we knew we needed to
think -- the glass --
I'm sorry, I should have said
that -- is about 165 pounds.
So we just simply can't lift that.
And the frame would have
added another 85 pounds.
So we needed to find a way to --
how we're going to put the map in,
how we're going to
put the glass on top,
and how we're then going
to display the map.
So this is the part where
the map can be introduced
to the encasement bottom.
And then this whole cart, if you
will, can get wheeled underneath,
and the frame is actually
temporarily held
on what can be best
described as some table legs.
Okay, so they will be removed later.
The frame also holds the glass.
So the encasement will be wheeled
underneath with some scissor jacks.
The encasement will be lifted until
it will actually lift the frame
with the glass and the table legs.
Now it can be secured, and
the table legs can be removed.
And once that is done, then
we can add more scissor jacks
and get it in the upright position.
This is highly simplified.
This actually includes several
scissor jacks and several stages.
But this is about the way --
it's a slightly steeper angle
as I could draw it here,
but we could not go any further
because then we have to really put,
you know, secure it with the front.
And that just wasn't what we
wanted to do, so hence the angle,
which is not great for display,
but there was really
no other way to do it.
So there you go.
So that was the total package.
That is the total weight.
This is the best we could do,
and it's a small compact car
is what it comes down to.
So that meant we had to get in
the big guns because we, you know,
clearly don't have an
ability to do that.
So we had a rigger company come in.
You can see the two packages
on the flatbed truck.
One will hold the base that the
display can be turned upright on,
and the other one will
hold the actual encasement.
Flatbed truck, big crane, had to go
in through the Great
Hall, second floor.
There was no way that we
could get it up steps.
And so here you see some of the
folks trying to carefully --
once this crate goes in, very
carefully move it inside.
And then, of course, we had to
deal with the mosaic floors.
So we had to create an entire
path to make sure that none
of the floors were damaged.
And then once it came into
the northwest pavilion we had
to actually get a crane,
or create a crane,
to get the items out
of their crates.
But everything went beautifully.
And no hiccups there.
So that was fantastic.
So the next step was
to have Conservation crew
-- and I had a lot of fun.
This took about a day, but it was
really great -- to clean everything.
Now NIST had done some cleaning,
but we just wanted to really go
over everything with
a fine-toothed comb.
We did need a clean room.
That was sort of the
assumption on both sides,
"Well, we need a clean room."
We thought we needed a clean
room because of the seals,
and NIST thought we needed
a clean room because, "Well,
you wanted to do this
in a clean room.
This is conservation.
This is your thing."
And we said, "No, no, no, no.
We don't need that.
That's fine."
And they said, "Well,
we don't need it.
It's not a metal seal.
It's a Viton O-ring seal
that's much more forgiving.
We don't need that."
So we just -- we could just do it
in the exhibit hall, which is --
which saved us a little bit of work.
So here you have sort
of a good first image
of what the encasement looks like.
This is the base.
You have the encasement bottom.
And you have the frame on table
legs with -- that holds the glass.
So while that was done, the
platform had already arrived earlier
at the library because we
wanted to get the map ready.
So what I showed you in the earlier
image where we hinged the map
to the board, to the platform.
We were well done by the
time the encasement came in.
So here it's wrapped up, and
Conservation staff is walking it
through the various tunnels to
come from the Madison building
where the Conservation
Division is located
to the Jefferson building
exhibit hall.
We had done this path several times
because we really wanted
to make sure it fit.
And so we, again, did not
run into any surprises
by the time D-day came around.
So then on D-day, the map is ready.
It's on a temporary stand here.
Here is the encasement, so
the map is going to be placed
on a platform that's going to
be placed inside the encasement,
and that's going to be
wheeled underneath the glass.
So here's the map installed.
The seals have -- can we see the --
no, the seals are still
about to be added.
But here we're screwing
in the trim bars
to secure the platform
to the casement bottom.
Okay, so now seals have been
added, and now we're going
to very carefully wheel the entire
package underneath the glass.
So we had to do this
a couple of times.
Clearly this is very heavy.
You're sort of in a rut
when you start moving it,
and you have very little
time to adjust it.
So it took us a couple of times.
But then it finally worked.
So then it's a matter
of bolting the 92 bolts.
And here you see a final picture.
Think this is A.P. It was
a bit of a media circus.
There was a lot of press there,
so that made the whole thing
a little bit challenging.
But the good thing was
everybody knew what to do.
So it went actually -- the
whole thing was done with --
in the morning, and in the afternoon
we could already start the purging
process and getting the
oxygen out of the case,
and started introducing argon.
Just one thing about the
bolts, the bolts are tricky
because along the long sides we need
more pressure than on the corners.
This is what they figured out
when they broke the glass at NIST.
And in order for that not to happen,
they have these little gauges
that are very precise
distance gauges.
And so they know exactly
how much pressure to put on.
And that way the seal is perfect and
has not cracked a glass as of yet.
So as per schematic
drawing, I showed you how
that is being turned upright.
And now we can start
the process of purging.
So we're going to introduce
humidified argon gas.
We cannot just pure -- we cannot
just put pure argon gas in there.
That would be too dry.
So we have a little system
that takes the argon gas
through two flow meters,
and will bubble --
one of them will bubble
through water,
and then we have a
measurement device
that will get the relative
humidity to about 40%.
And so that 40% humidified argon gas
will be flushed through the system.
And it will come out at
this end of the manifold.
So this is called the manifold.
This was first thought of by
the former Preservation Research
and Science Division
Chief here at the Library.
And what this enables us
to do is to have all kinds
of measurement devices and
monitoring devices connected
to the manifold and not to the case
itself, because anytime we want
to put a measuring device
through the encasement itself,
it will create another hole,
and another possibility
for losing the seal.
So what are the measuring devices
that we then put on the manifold?
So we have two oxygen
measurements -- monitors.
We have humidity.
We also have a barometric pressure.
It's not connected to
the case, but we do want
to know what the barometric
pressure is going to be.
And then we have the
differential pressure monitors.
So we -- these are
backups of one another,
but these actually have two
distinctive different functions.
So we have a measuring
device that takes --
that measures the oxygen level going
from ambient, which is a little
over 20%, to about three.
And then the next one will
take it a step further
and takes it all the
way from 3% to 0.1%.
And the pressure sensors
are finicky.
It's very easy to get pressure
sensors when you have a flow of air.
It's much harder when
it's stationary.
And that is something that
subsequent generations
of these encasements have
been struggling with.
And that is something
that the current Chief
in Preservation Research and
Testing is very busy with.
So why is it important
that we do these things?
Okay, so relative humidity
won't change.
Temperature won't change too
much because we're very --
we're pretty well able
to keep the exhibit area
at a very steady temperature.
So that part is good.
But we can't do anything
about the weather.
We wish we could.
So barometric pressure will change.
And so that is in this graph --
sorry, there's a couple of graphs,
and then that's all
and I'll be done.
So there is barometric
pressure lined up here,
and temperature is lined up here.
So the -- okay, that's not
really vacuum engineer.
The engineer that really helped us,
Dr. Charles Tilford [assumed
spelling] with establishing
and monitoring this
environment, made this graph.
And it shows you the
safe zone, if you will.
Now if the temperature is pretty
much going to be constant,
then we really want to have --
you want to follow this line,
if you will, to make sure that the
encasement interior stays safe.
As soon as temperature rises
we're going to get this area.
And as soon as it drops
we're going to get there.
Or conversely, if barometric
changes will get us into a red area,
either too low or too
high, the same will happen.
So we're keeping close eye
on barometric pressure.
So this is March 2008, the
installation of the map was complete
in 2007, December of 2007.
So this is a couple of months later.
And it gives you an idea of the
range of barometric pressures
that this case experiences
on a daily basis.
But since then, like I said,
the temperature is constant,
it's really only the
barometric pressure that's going
to have an influence
on the differential
pressure inside the case.
And in fact, directly so.
So when one goes up,
the other one goes down.
So if I have a low barometric
pressure system coming through,
my case will balloon.
And conversely with a high
pressure system, it will contract.
So that looks really
bad, but the nice thing
about graphs is it's
all about scale, right.
So now it doesn't look so bad.
And we are well within the
threshold that NIST established
of 25 millibars that is considered
to be the safe zone for --
to make sure that we keep the seal.
So there are, however, some
doomsday scenarios where we could,
you know, go beyond that.
So that would not be good.
So one of them would be
if a beautiful winter day,
high pressure system coming through,
and for some odd reason
our heating drops out.
So temperature drops, gas contracts,
high pressure from
atmospheric pressure coming in.
That could, you know,
crack the glass.
This is not so likely to happen.
This could possibly happen,
we have -- I won't say --
we haven't gotten close,
but we've kept an eye on it.
A low pressure system like
Hurricane Sandy lands in Maryland
versus New York, coming through.
All the terrible things that happen
during those occasions might happen.
We might lose power, so
our cooling drops out.
So our case temperature might rise.
We have a low pressure
system coming through.
You know, we might lose the seal.
So it happens, so don't imagine
that the glass will
shatter, anything like that.
But what could happen is that we
get a little crack in the glass.
It is the pressure that will
cause that, and we lose the seal.
So that's not the end of the
world, but it's a bit of pain
to start the whole process over
again to replace the glass.
So we have a system where
we get emails when we are --
when circumstances are threatening
to get us close to that happening.
And once we do that, or once
we see that it's a little --
it's getting a little
too close for comfort,
we just open up the main valve,
and we'll introduce ambient air
into the system, let the
case sort of settle down.
Unfortunately we no longer
have an argon environment,
but we can reflush the case and
start the process over again,
and it will save us from
having to replace the glass.
Now just in case, we do have
a piece of spare glass sitting
in our warehouse, so
we could do that.
But we'd really like to avoid that.
So here we are, it's all set.
All the monitoring devices
are sitting on the back.
You can't see them, but
trust me, they are there.
And here is John overseeing
everything.
And so this is where
we are right now.
So like I said, successfully
completed in December 2007.
The seal performs much better
than we had possibly
imagined, which is great news.
And we [inaudible] it's
going to be 10 years sealed,
and definitely going to be 20 years
sealed -- or yeah, 20 years sealed.
And maybe by that time
we actually have
to replace the O-ring --
the Viton O-ring seals.
Not -- it's not anything to do
with its inability to keep it.
And another objective that I'm
very happy about is the fact
that we have now obtained in-house
ability to monitor conditions
and various situations if necessary,
and reflush the case if necessary.
I don't -- I'm not saying that
we could build a case like this,
but we can certainly maintain
this one, which is great.
Big project, lots of
people involved.
I'm just one of them.
And these are all the
folks that had a --
all of them a critical part
in this and made this happen.
That's really it.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: So Elmer will
take a seat, and pick up a mic,
and do any questions if you'd like.
If there are any questions.
>> Elmer Eusman: Can
I stand up here?
>> John Hessler: Yeah, yeah.
Tom?
>> Question for you, going
back to your very first slide,
there was a question there about
access to the original document.
I'm thinking back to -- I have been
around here for a number of years,
and the Washington Map
Society, and I had a chance
to see the map before
it was encased.
I know that John Hessler and Chet
Van Duzer have done a tremendous
amount of research on that
map, the original map.
Books have been published,
and all of this has happened.
In the years since this
map has been encased,
Chet has gone on further using
multispectral imagery and all kinds
of other things with the
Martellus map and other documents.
What provision is there as the
technologies get better and better
to understand maps and research
maps, what provision is there
to take the map out of the
case at a certain point in time
to do additional research, and then
perhaps remounting it in the case?
>> Elmer Eusman: Well, I'm glad
I'm not making that decision,
but I would say that
we could do that.
Well, first, couple of things.
Hyperspectral imaging has been
done of the map before it went in.
And that's all thanks
to Dr. Fenella France
who made sure that that was in play.
So we have high-resolution images
in -- at different bandwidths.
Could we take the map out?
Yes, absolutely we can.
And in fact, NIST made sure
that we had a way to do that.
It will be wheeled out.
It will be flattened.
We'll get the table legs out that
are still there, and we can do that.
But it's a big production.
And it will probably take
some direction from people
that are not me to say, "You
know, it's really time for us
to have another look at it, and it's
important for us to pursue this."
We can certainly facilitate that.
But it is a bit of a production.
>> John Hessler: Yeah, and
Tom, I think when we put it
in we can't really
foresee any research reason
that we'd ever have
to look at it again.
If we do look at it again,
when it comes out it's going
to certainly be another round
of hyperspectral imaging
from a conservation perspective
to see whether there's any
changes or anything like that.
But I think when we
put it in, we really,
after doing hyperspectral imaging on
it, couldn't foresee any real reason
that we'd ever have to take it out.
We even have things like
fiber samples that were saved,
ink samples that were saved in
case there was future testing
that might need to be done
on it, from that perspective.
But I think it's in there
for another decade, so.
>> Elmer Eusman: Yeah, I also
want to say on a personal level,
as fun as this project
was, I am not --
you know, I am not a big
proponent of this at all.
I think if it was up to me, I would
take the map out, put it away,
and put another facsimile up.
So this is not a conservation-driven
project,
but it is certainly a
conservation-guided project.
And the driver here was the desire
to have this on long-term display
to increase access not just for
scholars, but really for the public.
>> Thank you.
>> John Hessler: Ben?
>> [Inaudible] get the valves
in place damage anything.
So [inaudible] there are ways
of dealing with that in terms
of controlling the
wavelength, etcetera.
But looking sort of
to the distant future,
what's another hypothetical model
where you could eliminate the map
with really minimal damage?
I mean, light wavelengths are always
going to be light wavelengths,
but is there any sort
of hypothesis about --
or conjectural model about a
different way of illuminating?
>> Elmer Eusman: No, it's
a fundamental principle
that light carries energy, you know.
And it doesn't matter whether
you illuminate something
under light level, or there's
a low light levels or high.
It's accumulated effect.
It just builds up, and keeps going,
and the process will just take a lot
of -- it will proceed a lot
faster under certain circumstances
and higher-energy wavelengths.
But the principle remains
the same, yeah.
>> John Hessler: When you
think about the reason
that the map survived, in fact,
it was because it was bound
into a book, and closed,
and put away,
and never saw the light
of day again.
So we have it that way.
You know, a curator when they
hear the word permanent display,
you just -- or a conservator,
you nearly want to,
you know like, "No possible way.
We don't ever want to do that."
And we also don't want to
have the fact that, you know,
it's lasted for 350 years, and us
in 50 years, you know, destroy it.
So this was one of those
very bizarre projects.
And it really was driven by
the agreement of purchase,
which in fact required
permanent display.
So it was a big issue.
>> Elmer Eusman: Yeah, John is
absolutely right, putting something
in an album and having direct
contact with the pages,
and putting something in is
fantastic for conservation purposes.
It's just, you know, it's
not accessible that way.
As John said, it wasn't
actually Renaissance prints,
but Renaissance drawings in a
collection at Rotterdam I worked on.
There were 200 of Fra Bartolomeo
drawings, and they were exquisite.
And they had never been touched.
And the main reason is oxygen
cannot really get to it.
Air pollution cannot
really get to it.
And they were in fantastic shape.
But because they weren't accessible,
and because they were
chalk drawings,
and every time somebody does
go through them, pages flex,
and chalk will fall off, we
decided -- well, not we --
it was decided that
put them in mats.
But ultimately I think if
they would have been kept
in the album pages they would have
done great for hundreds of years.
>> John Hessler: Dava?
>> So you talked about a
10-year limit, maybe 20 years.
As a -- it's a two-part question.
As a conservator, would you
like to see the map put
away somewhere for safety?
And might the new website
allow that?
Might that be considered
access to the map
that would satisfy the
purchase agreement?
>> Elmer Eusman: So the answer
to the first question is yes.
But I need to be that
advocate, right?
And it's not my decision.
It is just for me to
say all things --
where I'm coming from is I'm
not concerned with access.
I'm concerned with preserving
this for generations to come.
But ultimately it's not my
decision, and then well,
the only thing I can do is to say,
"Well, okay, if that's what we want
to do, if the need to make this
accessible trumps my desire
to conserve this map
for future generations,
then let me at least guide
this project and do this
in the most responsible
way possible."
Whether this website
will answer some
of this need, I really don't know.
It's a big -- there's a
continuing discussion about, "Well,
why don't we just put
out facsimiles of things,
because the light levels can go up,
people don't know the difference.
Why just don't you do that?"
That's ethically probably
uncomfortable.
And so we still do what we do.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
It's a process.
It's multiple people who
are in the mix discussing
and then weighing various options
to see what will be
the best thing to do.
Now that it's in the case
I'm very comfortable with it,
very comfortable with it for there
-- it to be another 10 years.
And then I don't know
whether we will renew it,
or whether we by that time
have decided, you know, it's --
"We've done what we set out to do,
and I think it can go back now."
>> John Hessler: One of
the unfortunate things
that this case has
done, and the documents
at NARA have done is they've created
a monster -- at least I think so --
because everyone who donates
an expensive map says, "Oh,
I want to put it on
permanent display."
And so you're -- you know, you --
"We know you can build these cases."
And so again, as Elmer said, this --
these decisions are made way
above our -- we can advocate.
We can say we don't want to, we're
not comfortable, we don't think,
but in the end if the money
is raised and they say,
"We're going to do
it," we have to do it
in the best and safest way possible.
So I am also -- I would
take it out tomorrow.
If it was up to me, the map would be
removed from display and placed back
in the book, and the book would then
be displayed every now and again.
So -- and we could have the
website and a facsimile.
But again, above our paygrade.
>> Could you just tell us a
little bit about the material
on which the map was printed?
The paper?
What has your analysis shown?
>> Elmer Eusman: I cannot really.
I mean, it is -- it's very
stable 15th-century paper.
We have certainly looked
at the watermarks.
I am not the expert on this.
I don't know whether
Sylvia or Heather is here,
or whether they're willing
to say anything about that.
Or I could put you in touch,
but that's not knowledge
I have on top of my head.
>> Why don't you just
come up, since you're --
>> John Hessler: No, no, no.
You're standing there.
Come on, may as well.
>> Elmer Eusman: Or maybe afterward.
>> John Hessler: Or maybe you
just want to talk afterward?
>> Elmer Eusman: Yeah,
that sounds good.
>> John Hessler: Any
other questions?
>> I'll just --
>> John Hessler: Oh.
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm Sylvia Albro.
I'm a paper conservator
working under Elmer.
And when the Waldseemuller map came
in, I know that Heather Wanser,
another senior paper conservator,
did do beta radiographs
of all of the pages.
So we have a record
of the watermark,
and we know other maps printed
by Waldseemuller are
on that same paper.
It's a very, very high-quality
paper, high calcium content.
There's a bit of an uncertainty of
whether it comes from the region
of Alsace or Northern Italy.
It's a crowned watermark
that's been used
in other Strasberg-based
publications,
so information is out there.
>> John Hessler: Yeah, the
watermarks are rather strange.
It's a pair of crowned watermarks.
The mark -- watermarks that
are found on the 1507 map --
not all the sheets have watermarks,
but the ones that are watermarked
are these pairs of crowns --
that watermark also
appears on the Carta marina.
That watermark also appears in
the 1513 Ptolemy by Waldseemuller.
So the three major Waldseemuller
extent publications have
that watermark.
Sylvia and her team, who had
a Ptolemaic atlas study team
in the conservation collection --
Conservation Division recently
discovered a rather strange thing
that scholars are going to be
puzzling over for a long time,
that that watermark also appears
in the "Nuremburg Chronicles."
The connection between those
two is unknown and peculiar.
So that's kind of where
we are on the watermarks.
And anyone else?
One more? Well, I want to
thank you all for coming,
and I want to thank Elmer for --
[ Applause ]
And I also want to invite you all at
between 1:00 and 3:00 this afternoon
in the Geography and Map Division,
which is in the basement
of the Madison building.
We will be having an open house.
At that open house, the original
Sammelband will be on display,
so if you want to see the
original book the 1507 map was in,
which still contains
the Carta marina,
which still contains the
[inaudible], you can see it there.
We will also have many
Ptolemaic atlases out,
and also there's a little
bit of a strange thing
on the Carta marina
which -- sheet six.
There are actually two sheet
sixes of the Carta marina.
One is printed, one is a manuscript
drawn in the hand of Schoner.
That will also be on display.
So we invite you down to the
Geography and Map Division from 1:00
to 3:00, and I want to
thank you all for coming.
I hope to see you there [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.